speaking of voicemails I do have a
voicemail line that line is that phone
number is two one nine to david p 2192
david p here's a voicemail i received in
the last day or two let's take a listen
hey David I love your show and I watch
you on YouTube almost every day and I
was curious about whether you have more
viewing on youtube or on television
because as much as I love your show I
would have no idea that my dad actually
watches you regularly on free speech TV
when I walked in the room I said that's
David Pakman you watch him I didn't even
know he was on TV so I was just
wondering if you could elaborate on how
much of your audience is from TV and how
much is from YouTube Thanks yeah listen
up you can watch the david pakman show
anywhere it doesn't make a big
difference to me as long as you are
getting what you want out of it we are
on TV we are on youtube it's all
absolutely fantastic and uh peace and
love and we we love it also great for
everybody who's watching no matter what
on today's bonus show we will talk about
Apple eliminating the headphone jack
from future devices what does that mean
a lot of people not really understanding
what's going on with that a lot of
questions about what I have been reading
lately I will talk about that a little
bit we do have an upcoming david pakman
show planned vacation and i do want to
mention that tell people about it so
that there are no surprises when we do
start our vacation and of course there
is only one way to get access to the
bonus show and that is by signing up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership and if you like if you're up
for paying the regular membership price
thank you that's absolutely great if the
normal prices present any level of
financial hardship for you we do have a
coupon code which is Patriot for t.h.a.t
are I OT 40 which will give you a very
very nice discount off of the membership
of your choosing you enter that in the
coupon code when checking out uh I
recommend doing it I've never heard of
anything better than being a david
pakman show
member but I know that I'm probably uh
hearing only from people who who are big
big fans of the show I look forward to
talking to you on the bonus show